la république dominicaine environ 800 000
des personnes ont été déplacées 19
les communautés sont isolées à cause de
la pluie causée par la tempête
projet de loi tropical aussi les autorités
a signalé que les pluies ont causé
dégâts à 1 586 maisons, 3 ponts et
également 75 aqueducs en plus de 159 mille
les gens qui se retrouvent sans
alimentation électrique par contre
Ils ont indiqué que 23 provinces maintiennent le
alerte du comité d'urgence confirmée
que la tempête d'avril s'est maintenant transformée
dans la vague tropicale continue de provoquer
les précipitations dans le pays donc
a recommandé de naviguer à proximité du
périmètre côtier